En effet, je conduirai cette liste
pour les élections européennes de juin prochain
et je tiens d'ailleurs à remercier Éric Zemmour pour
sa confiance. Je suis heureuse de travailler avec lui,
en complémentarité,
lui qui sera notre candidat naturel, bien sûr,
pour les élections de deux-mille-vingt-sept.
l'opportunité de rassembler les électeurs de droite
autour d'une grande bataille,
euh, et je pèse mes mots, qui. Euh.
Et civilisationnels, qui est historique et vitale,
qui est celle de La Défense de notre identité,
notre culture,
de nos valeurs
qui sont aujourd'hui
menacées par la soumisation migratoire
et par l'islamisation.